hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash episode 11 video the
reverse flash returns just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it the
whole episode was really like a reverse
flash explainer abarth on explainer so
let's get going
what better time to do a new round of
the reverse flash ring giveaway so all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video how did you get your suit into
that little ring really that's all you
want to ask me so what I'm gonna do is
top 10 WTF just because there were so
many big moments in this episode so
starting with number 10 the reverse
flash tries to learn about Barry Allen
and what time he's from there's a whole
lot of explaining that we have to do
about time travel what's going on with
them changing things and how it affected
Cisco and the end of the episode but
basically at the beginning of the
episode we learned that eobard thawne
doesn't know anything about Barry Allen
he just knows about the flash and is
trying to find the time period he was
originally from because up to this point
they have already been battling across
space and time so ear Bart Thawne uses
this truck accident the beginning of the
episode to find out where the flashes
from finds the time period and if you
note Gideon is the same voice from
legends of tomorrow they cast a new
actress called Amy Pemberton they said
that they asked Morena Baccarin to come
back but because she was so busy with
Gotham and doing other things like
Deadpool she didn't have time to
continue being the voice of Gideon so no
more Morena Baccarin Gideon which is
kind of a bummer that's ok onto number 9
WTF the turtle is dead and of course
Harrison wells denies everything Jay
Garrick plants the seed of doubt in
Caitlin like every time something bad
happens
Harrison wells always seems connected to
it remember Harrison wells technically
is not evil even though he's doing very
bad things he just wants to save his
daughter and feels like there's no other
option it's better to call him an
antagonist but Cisco does reference you
know trying to use the turtles powers to
try and defeat zoom Harrison wells is
already working on that problem that
that's why he took that sample from
turtle when he killed him so no worries
there they got what they needed from
turtle on the number 8 WTF Harrison
wells discovers the secret of Cisco's
power I solved Einstein's riddle when I
was 10 he discovers that the easiest way
to make Cisco vibe is to make him pee
his pants so he puts on the
reverse-flash costume and takes this go
to the Time Vault which I
yes is what they're calling the gideon
room so we'll just think of that as the
time fault
but gideon there isn't there anymore the
producers explained at the beginning of
this season that they no longer have
access to gideon no idea that actually
does anything special now other than
being this crazy freaky braille room at
cisco calls it on the number seven WTF
Kaelin explains what's going on with Jay
Garrick to Barry and why they need to
find his doppelganger Kalyan wants to
replace Jays cells with healthy cells
from his earth-1 doppelganger in the way
she explains it they didn't really
explain it when Jay Garrick was like I'm
sick they didn't really specify the
particular some of the sickness only
that he was dying so now it sounds like
whatever happened when zoom took his
speed that is what is slowly killing Jay
Garrick is not like he had cancer before
he got the Speed Force number six WTF
the flash versus the reverse-flash round
one there's this really funny exchange
where Barry's like dude you're dead
thanks bro good to know
by the way now that I know where you're
from you're gonna be dead soon too so
the whole reason for taking Tina McGee
is so that the reverse-flash can get
back to the future so that he can go
back in time again to when Barry was a
child and kind of set off the plot line
for season one and then we get our
time-travel explainer so number five WTF
time remanence explained Harrison wells
explains how reverse flash can still be
alive if Eddie Thawne killed himself
if you watch the episode and you're
still confused think about it this way
eobard thawne from the future like the
one we're seeing in this episode was
inside the Speed Force when Eddie Thawne
killed himself so the Speed Force acted
as this time bubble that protected him
so he was not subject to the effects of
changing the timeline on the number four
WTF Cisco can vibe into the future in
Harrison wells supercharges a pair of
his goggles so that now they have some
control over it really what it does is
it simulates the fear response so that
he gets charged with adrenaline and
that's how they're controlling it
they're using the goggles to regulate
that something Harrison wells said made
me turn my head though he said I can
control your vibe ability now meaning
that he might induce Cisco to vibe even
if Cisco doesn't want to in the future
and when he started to bleed from the
nose I actually thought that was gonna
be a side effect of them super charging
his ability like oh you know you can
make it that much more powerful but it's
going to hurt you like they're not going
to give Cisco
unlimited ability to see into the future
that's almost like overpowering the hero
characters so the way they explain that
is that Cisco just gets like this
massive headache so it is going to
continue to harm him just a little bit
when he uses the goggles so it's not
like he's just gonna walk around 24/7
with the goggles on now on the number
three WTF iris says her goodbyes to her
mother very emotional
she's like I wish I could be here for
Wally so he could work his anger out and
I could be here to explain it for him it
takes her a little while but iris is
able to help Wally realize that he needs
to go say goodbye to his mother and it's
really just kind of setting off their
arc Wally's gonna be big in the back
half of the season this is just the
beginning of that him slowly moving past
his mother's death but it's not gonna
happen right away Wally has all this
pent-up aggression and anger and he
hasn't even had any scenes with Barry
yet as a whole other thing that we have
to talk about once they finally get some
scenes together but speaking of moving
forward on the number two WTF patty
leaves the show for I don't know how
long I don't know if she'll be back for
the finale but I'm pretty sure based on
what the producer said she's not gonna
be in the next couple of episodes but
they do have that final moment where
they leave things on a good note where
she kind of cleverly tricks Barry into
revealing he's the flash I like the way
they left things you know Barry like
stops blurring his face and he's like I
just wanted to make sure everything was
okay that's kind of his way of
acknowledging yes I am the flash but one
of the big things that this is teeing up
is the fight against zoom like doubling
down on the quest to defeat zoom it's
kind of like wall-e moving past his
mother's death like both characters
moving forward and finally on to my
number one WTF no surprise this is a tie
between Jay Garrick from Earth one being
hunter zolomon from the comics holy crap
in number two Barry being forced to send
ebar Thawne home knowing full well that
he will go back in time right after and
kill his mother and there's nothing he
can do to stop it so I'll start with a
hunter zolomon stuff first this is where
we get into like our biggest comic book
Easter eggs from the episode so if you
haven't read the comics during Geoff
Johns run they did this big transition
where they updated a lot of the classic
characters a lot of the classic villains
they also updated the reverse-flash so
during the Silver Age the reverse
flashes name was eobard thawne he was
professor zoom when Geoff Johns took
over the flash title he updated the
character and he
past the mantel of the reverse-flash
onto a character named hunter zolomon
who took the name zoom so already
everybody's freaking out going does that
mean that jay garrick from earth one is
zoom on the TV show no not necessarily
all we can say now is that they're just
using the name there there might be more
Jay Garrick twists but it's a way of
explaining to you the Jay Garrick can't
use his earth-1 doppelganger because Jay
Garrick cells were mutated when he got
the Speed Force they're so different
from his doppelganger from hunter
zolomon cells that they can't fix in to
use Jay no idea if the TV show is gonna
do anything with the hunter zolomon
character they could always use it as a
big story arc in a future season if they
want the seed has been late like they
have planted the seed of hunter zolomon
zoom my guess is is that it's not gonna
rise above that level yet but we might
see this Hunter's old amant character
pop up again if you want to have some
fun but you don't want to read the
comics hunter zolomon from the comics
was essentially the Eddie Thawne
character in season 1 basically Eddie
got the hunters on Lamont Ark but they
gave him a Thawne name and they used the
character in a different way
so the TV show kinda has already done a
hunter Zola mod story they just they
didn't use the name
moving on to big reverse-flash explainer
of course it's a big WTF twist the Barry
has to set his greatest enemy free he
has to help him get home so that he can
go back and kill his mother in order to
save his friend like he's picking
between his mother and his friend but
earlier in the episode Harrison wells
already said that his mother was going
to die no matter what they did there's
nothing they can do to change that
couple really big things happen when
Barry and then Cisco talked to you Bart
Thawne in the cell so once Cisco kind of
reveals that you Bart Don is responsible
for all this so he does the thing that
Harrison wells tried to stop Barry from
doing like don't tell him about any of
this this is how he learns about us and
comes back but then Barry when he goes
to talk to him later and is like why do
you hate me so much
eobard thawne tells his story from the
comics his backstory now they've changed
a couple times in the comics and like I
said they're been a couple different
versions of the reverse-flash but
there's a couple fun stories from the
Mark Waid run in the Jeff Jones run that
tell the eobard thawne backstory what
Jeff Jones did is he essentially
expanded on the Mark Waid story mark
because Mark Waid came earlier he came
during the 90s Jeff Jones came about ten
years after that so he didn't
necessarily retcon anything that Mark
Waid
done but when he says he idolized the
flash that's all true it all happened in
the comics when eobard thawne is growing
up in the 25th century the flash doesn't
exist he's been dead for a long time
there's no Speed Force he learns about
him gets really inspired wants to become
him becomes infused with Speed Force
himself and that eventually time travels
into the past to try and meet Barry
Allen meet his idol but he ends up in
the flash Museum and accidentally learns
that he is destined to become professor
zoom the Flash's greatest enemy and it
drives him crazy so it becomes this
self-fulfilling prophecy and that sets
off the saga of the flash versus the
perverse flash and then that's
essentially that's like a combination of
the Mark Waid backstory with the Jeff
John's backstory Geoff Johns was like a
slightly bigger version of that
originally in the comics I think the way
professor zoom learns about Barry Al
learns about the past is in a very back
to the future way where he finds an
almanac and that's how he knows which
time to go back to visit but big
reverse-flash explainer in how
heartbreaking is it to know that he's
just gonna turn right back around go
back to when Barry was a child try to
kill him and it's gonna set off the
storyline from season one so let me know
in the comments what was your favorite
moment from the episode and do you think
that we're gonna see hunter zolomon pop
up in some odd way in the future I'm not
expecting him or Jay Garrick to be zoom
but I do think that they might try to
use the hunter so lamont character in a
funny way in the future just just to
have some fun if he didn't see it next
week's episode is also going to be the
tarpit episode he was a character that
Geoff Johns created in the comics Geoff
Johns is mostly known as a writer but
he's also an artist too and as a kid he
created his own comics one of those
characters he later wrote into the flash
and it was called tarp it so-now tarp it
is gonna be on the show so a character
that Geoff Johns wrote as a little kid
is now gonna be on TV which i think is
really cool
moving on to giveaway time
congratulations to just Mashiro you in
the reverse flash ring that I was giving
away in that Justice League video that I
did last night
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I get your contact
info what's gonna happen with the
current giveaway is it'll just stay open
till legends of tomorrow so I'll post
arrow tomorrow then legends of tomorrow
on Thursday if you guys haven't seen
there's some really cool new firestorm
powers that are gonna be happening on
legends of tomorrow this week and
tomorrow on arrow
Felicity is gonna take a shitload of
drugs it's gonna be the best thing ever
prescription-strength
Felicity Smoak is the best version of
felicity smoak so just in case you guys
haven't seen it there was a big dark
side Justice League WTF teaser that I
posted yesterday you can click here to
learn all about that and you can click
here for all my other flash and arrow
videos thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight